what i want to do over in this video is
kind of give a a back of the envelope
way for thinking about a conundrum that
the khan academy is facing right now and
you could do a little bit more of a
precise way with present valuing and all
of that but this will give you a pretty
good sense of how to make this decision
so we're seriously looking at office
space i've changed these numbers to
simplify things a little bit
but there's a nice office and it's going
for 2 000
per month and then there's this dingy
office it's really too dingy it's a
converted nightclub and it's really too
dingy to be a respectable place to work
but it's going for
one thousand dollars a month and i talk
to a contractor and the contractor once
again i'm simplifying these numbers
these numbers aren't the exact numbers
but it makes the math a little bit
simpler the contractor says it would
cost us
about ten thousand dollars to get this
dingy office to the condition of the
nice office and in either situation
we are thinking about a
24 24 month lease so two year lease 24
month lease
and the contractor said it would take
one month
it would take one month of work to get
the dingy office space up to speed so
when i talked so the nice office space
land landlord he says look it'll be 20
4-month lease you could just occupy it
it's ready to go the dingy office space
i talked to him about this idea of
us investing money and repairing it
he's like okay if you need to repair it
i'm you know he's kind of you know not
the easiest person to deal with he says
i'm going to charge you an extra month
of rent so even while i'm repairing it i
have to pay rent so that he'll say i'm
willing to do a 25 month
contract a 25 month lease with you
so 25 months so you could still once you
repair it you still get two years of
surface from service from the dingy
office so which one should i do and i'll
tell you my my emotions i want to do the
nice one because i don't want to spend
ten thousand dollars and and make this
all nice and then two years later uh the
landlord could raise the rent but let's
just think about it rationally which one
makes sense and the easiest way to think
about that is what is the effective
amount of rent on in the very back of
the envelope way that we're paying for
the dingy office so if you think about
it over the course of the 24
months that we're going to well if you
think about it over the entire lease
we're going to have 25 months we're
going to pay a thousand dollars per
month so it's going to be 25 000
plus 10 000 to repair it so plus 10 000
i'll just write 10k like i did before
plus 10k and in terms of the useful life
because over here when we're saying per
month every month here is useful so how
many useful months are here well we're
going to spend one month to repair it we
only get 24 useful months so we only get
useful months so the per
so if you view it this way not doing any
fancy present valuing just back of the
envelope it is 35 000
35 000
over
over 24 months and so let's get our
calculator out i guess it's not pure
back of the envelope but pretty clear
clearly pretty close to pure back of the
envelope 35 000
divided by 24
is equal to 1458
so this is equal to approximately 1
458 dollars
per month so even though i don't want to
invest in this property and i'm only
going to be able to use it two years and
this person is going to be able to raise
the rent after that it actually still
makes a lot of sense
it still makes actually almost 500 a
month of cents or more than 500 a month
of cents in this kind of back of the
envelope way to get the dingy office and
repair it